so we literally had stunts go and you
know rigged up in our on our set with
wires and actually have these characters
being slammed around and moved we wear
my prayer my tentacles bite I'm Lorraine
I might have fallen from space I'm like
doing this radius show we talk about all
the most 9t stuff in the Marvel Universe
oh and if we're gonna talk 90's let's
talk about this higher further faster
baby Marvel Studios Captain Marvel is
now available on digital HD and it's
coming to blu-ray and DVD on June 11th
I'm obsessed oh listen I can't wait for
all of you is the blooper reel deleted
scenes all the stuff I want more please
oh my god cuz I flirt in love this book
especially because of all the 90s
goodness I'm talking fashion soundtracks
so good oh the settings come on
Blockbuster Video what Oh bringing me
back and we're gonna be talking more
about the 90s today but I think first we
should talk about the fact that I got to
chat with visual effects supervisor
Christopher Townsend all about creating
gusta Cats
cool secret skills the kree-skrull
battle and Captain marbles big fall but
spoiler warnings ahead if you have not
seen this film but for those of you who
have you are in for a treat this is
super cool let's watch
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
I am here with visual effects supervisor
Christopher Townsend hello hi how you
doing
I'm very well so everyone has seen the
film by now if not what have you been
doing with your life get it together
people I want to talk about some of the
visual effects that we can finally kind
of discuss because it's coming home for
home release so first of all I know we
were all very excited to meet goose the
cat there's a lot more to goose the cat
then maybe meets the eye like a pocket
universe full of tentacles or something
like that yes as you're starting to
create this alien creature where do you
start I think with as with with most of
these things with sort of these
characters you you go back to the comics
and you look at the comics and you look
up poster art and you look at the art
that's been done of what what is the
Fleur Caen
so it's this big gooey goopy you know
Trump you know terrifically sized
monster sort of thing the burst out of
his cap and then goes back to inside
again and I think the fun part was she
was trying to have that juxtaposition
between the two and when you're bringing
that to life obviously the the Fleur
Caen will interact with the actors how
do you get him to interact with other
characters and pull it all together it's
all very carefully carefully
orchestrated we have one particular
scene where the elite fighting force the
Kree guards are coming in and our are
being slammed around so we literally had
stunts go and you know rigged up in our
on our set with wires and actually had
these characters being slammed around
and moved and flipped and flops and
things all that stuff is is very
carefully planned out in our
pre-visualization moment in our previous
time and we figure out exactly how you
know what the moves need to be based on
what the tentacle tentacles are going to
do so you sort of work backwards
that's where visual effects sort of fits
in the middle as it were so speaking of
the Kree and the scrolls there is this
large fight between the two of them and
there are a lot of characters there how
many characters are being brought in
through visual effects and how many are
actually there we actually shot out ways
that is the scene called Topher on the
planet to offer and
we went and we shot this at a quarry for
a couple of weeks because of the
complexity of you know you're shooting
outside you're shooting at night you're
shooting in fog which you know there's
there's never the same all these sort of
things made it incredibly difficult to
actually do it to pull it off but I
think what you see at the end is this
sort of big wide scope of things there
are maybe 40 or so real you know actors
in full makeup and prosthetic masks and
helmets and costume and everything else
running around in that in that that
sandy sort of quarry and then we've
added you know easily just as many
characters on top in in digitally it's
really a mix between the sort of the the
traditional sort of stunt work and and
visual effects there is an epic scene at
the end where Captain Marvel is falling
it is harrowing how do you place that
because obviously we can't drop brie
Larson yeah so a lot of all of us a lot
of what we do is you're trying to make
the the impossible possible and so and
also making it hopefully look real so
that an audience is there and never
questions it and and there are many
things we could have tried we could have
tried skydiving we could have tried
these are the wind tunnels we could have
tried her on wires we could have tried
all sorts of different things one of the
things we realized very quickly was that
for what we needed for her in this very
specific moment is is is to be able to
just use a digital double of her and be
just close in on her face and be able to
use her face and her expressions where
necessary well and there's some other
performance involved too because there's
there are some folks in green-screen
suits as well there are there are people
there that are moving her around in the
blue screen suits and they're using that
to try and puppeteer her to make it feel
like she's floating because one of the
problems is obviously when you're you
know you're literally on wires you're
being supported in a cradle or if you're
on a on a backboard where you're just
being sporting your legs send tend to go
down so you need to sort of make you
feel like someone is moving around in a
more naturalistic way as you would when
falling and we used a lot of that not
only as some of it is actually is
literally in the film also a lot of it
was just used as reference so that we
can see how how Brie's body moves in a
particular way and how the costume moves
in a particular way when she's doing a
particular thing with her arms or legs
we also shot elements of
just of her face and so you could
imagine we were you know sitting in a
studio with her sitting in a chair and
she's got the helmet on and and we'd say
okay look scared
okay look over your left look over your
right oh now this is happening and she
was gonna she was a real trouper and
amazing to watch of true professionals
an actor being able to react to that and
pretend that they're falling and
panicking and looking but it's just
right here and it's just here and all we
all we all were capturing is just her
face and expressions and we take all of
that information and then we would we
would map that we would project that
onto a CG version of her so what you see
in the final film is generally a digital
version of her falling but with her
performance mapped on her face put on to
put on to the digital version of her so
you also got to create a very
interesting realm that we've never seen
in the Marvel Universe and it's hard to
say it's more of a consciousness we'll
say the supreme intelligence how did you
build that interaction world brain space
what do you call it we call it the
supreme intelligent chamber intelligence
chamber and I think it's a it was a
fascinating sort of bit of storytelling
that we were trying to do in there
there's a lot of exposition that happens
in that room there's a lot of sort of
definition of the characters that happen
but the the idea was that the the room
exists in a reality it's a virtual
reality but it should never look like
virtual reality should always feel like
a very real space but we wanted to keep
it a little bit surreal and we went
through many iterations from from
massive green hexagonal blocks to liquid
worlds to almost Salvador Dali sort of
you know sort of art we went through all
sorts of things but eventually ended up
back at this very minimalist sort of
almost a white room and a clean room and
the idea being that you can almost you
know whatever you want to conjure in
that room you can you can make happen
you know there's obviously there's a
point in the movie where we twist and
things get a bit more violent and
aggressive and then the room itself
begins to collapse and it was a really
interesting challenge to try and figure
out
to create something which would sort of
satisfy both the serene and the violent
all at once well it is beautiful and
very serene and I would very much like
to have that in my home not the latter
half yes
but the first part very nice thank you
so much
you're very welcome oh my pleasure you
guys be sure to watch Marvel Studios
Captain Marvel it's available for
digital download now there's so many
visual effects the brains behind these
things are bigger than me it's
mind-blowing it really is mind-blowing
but you know what else is mind-blowing
I've got one bit of itty bitty kitty
trivia for you guys I think this is so
cool you know ginger cats IRL in real
life tend to be genetically male so our
first hint that goose is a little bit
different is that she is female oh yeah
good find elven Alice I like that yeah
listen there are so many more fun
details from the comic books about
flirtiness let's talk about those right
yeah why don't we give these guys for
flirting facts from the comic okay
number one how the tentacles work so in
the comics Larkins contain these pocket
dimensions that don't just help hold
those pink tentacled Maas know they can
also carry anything up to the size of a
whole dang universe simply put clerk ins
are bigger on the inside well you know
in the comics these pocket dimensions
are actually very handy for
teleportation and time-travel if you
don't mind getting covered in a bunch of
pink goo it's it's damp
it's a damp way to travel but it's
convenient but also that makes sense of
how flirtin could just end up on earth
yes you also hey check this out fleur
khun's are oviparous word for you which
means like birds and reptiles they lay
eggs like lots of eggs like a crazy
amount of eggs yeah it's a lot of eggs
mm-hmm but don't say anything mean about
these cute little fluff flops because
they actually have human level
intelligence
um so brains and beauty and tentacle and
tentacles watch out for the tentacles
sealer and some new everyday all right
let's keep the fun rolling right with
more 90s goodness because it is Marvel's
80th anniversary and this month we are
celebrating you guessed it the 90s as we
take a walk down memory lane with our
friendly neighborhood toy hunter Jordan
Hembrough
toy rific let's check it out Earth's
Mightiest show fans what is that I'm
hanging out again with my good buddy
pop culture expert Marvel toy hunter
shortened Air Jordan Hembrough
Jordan welcome back my friend thank you
so much I am happy to be here I am happy
that you are here because as you can see
in front of you are some toys from a
wonderful decade that we are celebrating
here for Marvel's eighth anniversary the
90s a decade that I grew up in I was
born in 1985 all year for tree but I
cannot wait for a treat these are
sneaker snappers from the 1990s this is
what I love about these but hear me out
they snapped on the front of your
sneakers and it was like really a
wearable kind of cool piece of fashion
that you would wear it to tell everyone
I'm a Marvel fan I will tell you right
now I owned these sneakers there you go
really because my shoes always come
undone in the industry what we
essentially call something like this is
it branches from the toy category into
something we call lifestyle and that
means that basically you can use it
every day I'm speechless because I owned
these these these it what these are
yours
we talked about the 1990s and toys you
cannot not talk about the x-men
I definitely own this Murray I'm glad
Wolverine definitely had this one these
are classic x-men from toy biz during
the 1990s these toys ruled the toy
stores I got to take a second and talk
about rogue and you know what they
didn't realize how many females were
actually playing with the toys so what
happened was his rogue and storm were
short packed and what that meant is
there was only one or two of them in
every case of 12 toy biz started
realizing look we've got to start making
more rogue we have to start making more
storm we have started bringing these
strong female superheroes to life into
the toy industry and they started making
more and more of them Jordan I almost
don't want to move on yes this is my
childhood is sitting right in front
we've got more yes I know so let's do
some more I've got more all right
oh are you serious Biderman animated
series Daily Bugle playset this was on a
Christmas list anyone who grew up in the
90s loved the Spiderman animated series
it was a great piece it was expensive
yeah that's I remember the big thing my
mom was like no it was packed full of as
many you know factors as they can get in
you look at all the stuff that's on the
back you see all the characters the idea
behind the playset was to actually sell
more action figures because you created
a play environment and you created a big
player environment well guess what now
you gotta fill it yeah what are you
gonna fill it with more toys exactly
I've never ever thought I would ever be
this close to what everyone my heart is
always full when you come back to that
and I'm taking I'm taken back into my
childhood so great what am i right toys
from the 1990s and essentially what it
is is you put Hulk inside this giant
cage and he rages out and bursts through
the cage and it's pandemonium and fun
ensues I love when a choice is hey we're
gonna give you this cage the Hulk unit
yeah I actually want to bring it out of
rage I want to have you raised that way
okay so I'm gonna reach out with it
right
[Laughter]
it's worth it it's so worth it all the
rage Jordan thank you so much now my
pleasure if I'm if any of the fans out
there like me they're gonna want to know
more about where to find it more about
you and all these great toys tell us
more
absolutely okay well if you're
interested in toys you can find me on
Twitter at Jordan Hembrough Instagram at
Jordan Hembrough or if you feel so
inclined check me out at WWE would
heroes comm check it out because I'm
just gonna stand here and stare at these
and weep into my hands for a couple of
because this is so great oh that was
such a delight I feel like I was
transported to my child he was for sure
and I hate you shot Jordan Hembrough who
let me keep those sneakers stoppers oh
really
does this mean you're never gonna learn
to tie your shoes not for lack of trying
no but hey also that's very men Daily
Bugle pays playset also trying to steal
it I it's too big it wouldn't fit anyway
I couldn't hide that you need a better
cut need a flirt
full circle you guys yeah you tell us
what you would do if you could spend a
day with goose the cat akf lurk anything
and use the hashtag Earth's Mightiest
show see you next time I'm Lorraine and
I'm Langston and this is Marvel your
universe
thanks for watching Earth's Mightiest
show if you like this please like this
leave us a comment and subscribe to the
Marvel channel or click the box over
there to watch our last episode get your
flirting out of here please I can't
control this it's my legs